Mr. Reminder, please look at the member site for all announcements.
You know, most of you are accustomed to going to the member site. Please look at that.
Now we do have you want right updating you want your program updated for any reason.
Let's say you're not doing well. You need some updating because you are doing great.
And you want to add some programming for your spouse.
You're having different totally different symptoms. I'd like to add some information program to my overnight.
Whatever you want it will need to do. So I just need to know what that is.
Well now on the right resources page, which I know a lot of you are not utilizing the member site.
The way we want you to and I realize I get it. Everybody's busy.
It's crazy, but we put all that information on there for your benefit.
And I know you're not utilizing it. Some people aren't because some of the questions that you guys have are already answered.
So I do want you to start utilizing the website as best you can.
You'll see the life resources page. You'll see the this box right here.
This is request a right update box. Fill that out.
Just put your new symptoms change and diagnosis. What you want changed.
You know, we have people probably the most common reason why people want to update their life is.
Is they're doing better and they want to.
Or they would go to a program you'd for some coal war bedduty.
Like maybe they have Candida and they really would like to deal with that now.
Whatever you want, you could ask for that, understand that there is a fee for that.
The charge is per 15 minutes of my time.
So it's 135 dollars for that. Usually. I can do it.
In 15 minutes, but if you're, you know, we've had people in the past ask.
Well, that could take a long time.
So it could take an hour to do it.
Well, I have to charge for that just so you know.
So, but you can be as specific as you want
and ask me whatever you want.
Remember that everybody has access to all our other courses.
So please take advantage of those.
That might answer a lot of questions
that you might have too.
On the Zoom call page,
there's some updates to understand that.
So I know you don't read everything
because you don't know that there's changes
but I just want to update you.
You know, we have had like today.
We had a lot of questions this week
and I want to do my best to get through everybody's questions.
But we also need to be respectful
that you know, some people are asking 15, 20 questions
and I just have to pick and choose some of those questions.
So if there's questions that I've answered on other Zoom calls,
I'm going to point you that way to look that up
and to do your research on that.
Use this little thing right here.
All our blog is on our member's site now.
You'll notice that our blog is not on our website.
We literally had to take it down because FDA.
I wrote us a nice seven page letter saying
that we had to take all the fed, anything on Fed Medizol off
our website, anything on Fed Medizol off our store.
And a bunch of stuff on Kirkman.
It's just insane things that they can put at you
because we live in a crazy world today
and you can't fight these things.
You know, you either obey them
or they just literally come in and shut you down.
So we had to take all that information off.
So we moved our blog to the members only site.
So the general public can't see all of our 800 and some blog pages.
And Angie is updating our blog pages right now.
And she'll tell you that there's a lot of blog pages.
So that is all only available to you.
So take advantage of it.
And how do you get to it?
Go to any one of the members only site pages,
the private, well membership site pages
and go to that little icon right there
and you can click on it and search
for whatever your little heart desires to look for.
So if you want to search for something
that you can search for that,
then we're gonna put the pages on Fed Medizol
and details on that back up on that blog page soon
because it's gonna be only through a private site.
So it's not out to the public.
Okay, let's get to your questions here.
If they were at very low iron before,
I found out that I had a tumor in my colon
I did iron infusions.
At the time I was told I had any rashes to let them know
I had a small rash one week,
but it went away.
Now months later,
started in October the rash came back.
I put vinegar on it and it went away again.
In December it came back.
My doctor told me it is a fungus under the skin.
It is hard to get rid of.
Okay, so my question right there would be,
oh, how do they know that it's a fungus under?
I would ask those questions, you know,
is it what tested do they do to come up
with that diagnosis that it's a fungus under your skin?
She puts you on this medicated cream.
I've used it, it goes away,
but it comes back as soon as it gets back.
So because that is a steroid cream
that will decrease the inflammation and will,
but it doesn't really deal,
it certainly doesn't kill a fungus.
And certainly I'm going to deal with anything
that is subcutaneous or systemic that's causing it.
So still not dealing with the cause there.
I've used it, it goes away.
As soon as I cut back on the use,
I looked at the right ringworm program blog.
The suggestion was kelp capsules.
So a ringworm, a Google ringworm
and look at the images of ringworm,
because ringworm is very distinct and easy to diagnose
by looking at the pictures of ringworm.
If it looks like those pictures,
well then treat it as a ringworm
and certainly you could use kelp
and run the ringworm program,
I would also try some essential oils on it.
Started using vinegar again to keep it from getting worse.
I would definitely try some essential oils on it.
I would try some grapefruit seed,
grapefruit seed extract,
grape seed extract, grapefruit seed extract
as a liquid form.
You could also take that as a capsule form,
but I would look up that rash on some Google images
to make sure you're really dealing with what you're dealing with.
You have to understand,
and I'm going to talk about some people
who submitted some information about lab work.
The same is my answer is going to be the same for that.
The most common cause of some of these things
is a medication that you're taking.
So if you're on any medications,
that is the most common cause for a rash
is a medication you're taking,
which is a sensitivity to a medication.
So many medications affect your metabolic pathways
and can cause irritations and histamine disruptions
and rashes of basically your body,
you know, partly tried to detoxify through your skin.
So look at that as well.
What I'm saying is try to dig to the cause of that.
Good morning, Dr. Cutters.
You and your entire staff are in my prayers constantly.
Thank you for all you do.
I would like to know via a Zoom call question
without cheek swab testing.
How does that eliminate the ability
to update our RIFE program frequencies?
So I guess I already answered that question.
So go to the RIFE resources page on your member site
out at the bottom.
You'll see requests to RIFE update
tell you exactly what you're looking for.
So even if like, okay, my kids are getting worse.
You know, things are not improving.
Can we change things yet?
So, but give me your symptoms.
Tell me what's going on on that.
Question on the chat.
Any chance of getting a search feature on the mobile version.
That search box should be on.
So that search box should be on your, on this phone too.
If it's not, I'll ask Dustin.
It should be there, but we'll check into that.
Okay, I think this was this question was actually
for lastly, but I'll answer it again.
My CEA levels are still climbing.
I have mild edemia and my hemoglobin has dropped further
in the last month.
My doctor recommended they take higher supplementation
like ferrous gluconate, 324.
I'll answer it at a 24 milligrams twice a day.
Is there a better option?
Yes, though, the iron that I would recommend
is our clear iron that we have of the store.
It is an iron that is again, remember all your minerals
and iron is would be considered a mineral.
It needs to be double bonded and it should be a tracks
or I'll explain that with minerals in the past multiple times.
And that's what you should definitely be looking
at with edemia issues.
Have you heard anything about cilantro
being a good natural key later?
So this is this points back to your ability to go back
to you have access to all these courses.
The seven phases of detox course right here
is where we talk about the seven phases of detox.
So we talk about when you talk about a key later,
keylation is what I call phase zero
in the seven phases of detoxification.
And I go through the best detoxers for keylation to keylate.
You have to make sure all your other six phases are open
and you're at least working on those
before you start any keylation.
But certainly cilantro is a good key later.
Now cilantro would be classified
as a mild key later.
And I write much about that in the seven phases of detox book.
We really can't hurt yourself with cilantro.
You know, even if you weren't dealing
with some other phases of detox at the same time.
I started adding cilantro to my green smoothie daily,
just in case figured it couldn't hurt.
Yes, I would be with you 100% of that.
There really isn't any downside to cilantro.
cilantro is a food and a person could have a food sensitivity
to cilantro, but it's not very common.
That would be the only thing so long for that.
But cilantro is a great, very mild key later.
So this may be a wacky idea for continuing your registry
in the midst of this hyperregulation happening right now,
but at the off chance, it might lead somewhere.
So here it is.
If you could reorganize as a nonprofit, I really appreciate.
So I really appreciate this comment.
You're trying to help us out and to be able to help you out.
So understand, I really do appreciate that.
Reorganizing as an nonprofit doesn't solve anything
from a legal medical legal standpoint.
Because who the, the, the, the portals of government
that come after clinics like us are medical boards.
So the medical boards are basically not regulated.
So, so the president and the members of the medical board
or the chiropractic board or the naturopathy board
and some states, whatever,
legal entity is, is supposed to be regulating that industry.
The president of that board is, is assigned by a governor.
So the governor has the right to fire the president
of the medical board and to put somebody else in that place.
But it's one of those things that never happens.
So, I really appreciate this comment.
So a new governor comes in, let's say the old governor
was a Republican and the new governor as a Democrat,
the very, very rarely, if ever, do they go and change the,
change the, the presidents of these boards.
They're basically, once they're on there,
this is kind of a job for life until they retire.
And the truth is, is that they are judge and jury
over anybody they want to be.
So they can, they can file a claim
that you're practicing medicine without a license.
If you have a medical license,
they can file a claim against you
that you're disobeyed the rules of your licensure.
It's worse if you're licensed.
So, for instance, in the state of Minnesota,
there was a doctor, medical doctor,
and Dr. Jensen, there's multiple medical doctors
that this happened to during COVID,
that came up against what was,
what he was being forced to do
by the Minnesota Medical Association and treated COVID
and he just asked questions.
And of course, he had multiple complaints against him
and he had to get a lawyer and he had to defend himself.
Yada, yada, yada, just made his life completely miserable.
That's just really what they're doing.
They're trying to make your life completely miserable.
Now, if you're not licensed,
they have the right to come against you
and sue you in court for practicing medicine without a license.
And they define what that is.
So, it's by their definition.
So, you're really, again, you know,
up the creek without a panel
because you're basically fighting against definitions
and they're the ones that make the rules on definitions.
So, it's very difficult.
So, regardless of what corporate entity
that we were operating under, it doesn't make any difference.
If we are doing one-on-one consultations,
then they're saying that's practicing medicine.
So, you can't do that.
So, it's, that's the issue.
So, I do appreciate you trying to be creative.
We're trying to be creative as well.
We just need to stay legal.
Is there any news on AJ?
So, AJ is Ann's son.
So, Ann has been with us for about five years.
She has now gone full leave right now to deal with him.
He is doing a protocol for,
he was diagnosed with acute myeloid leukemia
in just a few months ago.
What do you got?
Super, super, super ill.
Near death, had to race to the hospital.
It was just a very crisis situation.
Discovered the leukemia, had to do some chemo therapy.
It just really had to.
It was the right thing to do.
He was very, very ill.
And I really do believe that the chemo saved his life.
And gets back to just our dogma, our doctorate,
you could say our doctorate as far as how you should treat yourself
regardless of whether your cancer or anything else.
It's not to be dogmatic.
So, what I mean is, and I've said, stated this in my book,
and verbally said it, you know, a hundred times,
which is, you know, don't be, take a dogmatic position in your treatment protocol.
So, I think it's wrong.
If that's a, if I get cancer and I'm like,
well, I'm not doing anything natural.
I'm going to do everything by oncologist said.
It's going to say that's all I'm going to do.
Well, I, to me, I think that's foolish
because you're taking this dogmatic approach against other things
that could possibly help you.
But I also think it's just as foolish to take a dogmatic position
that I would never do chemo.
There's no way I'm doing chemo.
Now, I understand people have experiences
and they have to make decisions.
But I still, even if you're, because you're emotionally a position against, you know, doing chemo,
I still think you have to keep it open by that, hey, if God's going to leave me that way,
then I'm going to do what He's going to tell me to do.
I'm not going to be dogmatically positioned.
I've opened to whatever God has for me, but He's going to have to change my heart
because He knows I don't want to do chemo or whatever that is.
So I just, in AJ's situation, it was the right thing to do.
He's got two more rounds of chemo.
He has had ups and downs to his health just.
He's back home right now from the hospital, but he spent a week in the hospital, you know,
last week with a serious crisis again, really bad crash.
So keep her in AJ and Tyler and husband and their whole family in your prayers.
I ask because it's just been really very difficult.
So she has taken a leave.
She has not been working.
She tried to come back part time.
It's just not going to work.
So just keep them in your prayers, please.
When I came to the clinic in August 2021 with all my supplements,
I was currently taking the only one you told me to stop taking was the homocysteine resist.
Now one and a half years later, it turns out my functional doctor was corrected
prescribing this and I'm going back on it.
Thanks to the Dutch test and the homocysteine test results.
But can you give me some insight as to how my uncorrected low methylation impact
by general health, cancer and detox these last 18 months?
I don't understand much about methylation, though you speak often about the danger of overmethylating.
What are the issues of low methylation?
What might I expect now that this is being corrected again?
Well, you might not, you probably won't see as far as what you could expect from me.
Corrected again, you probably won't have any symptom changes,
like changes you won't notice anything.
The idea that so here's why you don't want to be on methyl groups,
to any methyl groups, when you have cancer, methyl groups.
So a methyl group is from a biochemistry standpoint as a CH3.
Actually, looks like that when you would, you know,
from a biochemistry or a chemistry standpoint.
That is a methyl group that attaches to different components.
Now, what you have with different methyl groups that you take,
like a product called methylcomolomy,
which is a methylated B12, or methyl tetrahedral folate,
which is a methylated folate, is you have methyl donors.
So those products then donate methyl groups to your cells.
What happens in your cells is those methyl groups function
inside the cells at the nucleus of the cell,
and they help silence genes.
They turn off different genes, which is good and bad.
If you have cancer, and you have excess methyl groups,
you stand the potential of turtied off what are called tuber suppressor genes.
Tuber suppressor genes are genes that turn on when there's cancer growth.
And what they do when they turn on is they help cause a poptosis of the cancer cell
and help kill the cancer cell.
So hence, if you have excess methyl groups circulating in your body,
you will be silencing tuber suppressor genes.
And by silencing tuber suppressor genes,
you could propagate a cancer.
So you could increase the growth of an existing cancer.
You could increase the likelihood of cancer.
It's just like, okay, when women have, you know,
bronca genes, defects under bronca genes.
What are the bronca genes?
Bronca genes are just one tumor suppressor gene.
If you have defects under your tumor suppressor genes,
they have the potential of not working as well as if you didn't have defects on them.
So if you did develop a cancer cell in your breast, let's say,
and it starts to grow, and you have defects in the tumor suppressor genes,
they're not going to work as well.
What do they do?
They're supposed to turn on and cause a poptosis cell death
of that growing cancer.
Well, also, you could have perfectly healthy bronca genes,
and no defects whatsoever.
But you are over-methylating because you did a genetic test
that showed a MTHFR defect.
So then your naturopath or chiropractor said,
well, you need to be on methyl comolivated, methyl folate.
That's your problem.
And you're over-methylating.
And you are basically silencing tumor suppressor genes.
Well, it gets worse on that because if you have defects on your biopterid pathway,
which is a different metabolic pathway,
that biopterid pathway is how you make all your neural transmitters.
So you're dopamine in your serotonin in your GABA and all that.
You over-methylation pushes that pathway and you'll make access of that,
which can cause severe emotional imbalance,
and rage issues, and anger issues, and PMS issues,
and mix that with any other hormonal imbalance,
and you have a cocktail of lots of issues.
So I'm not in favor of simply using excess methyl groups to deal with the MTHFR gene defect.
The only reason why I would suggest you use methylated vitamins is if you have
elevated homocysteine.
So that would be the only reason to take methyl groups of my book.
And even if you have elevated homocysteine, you have to balance that with,
well, I also have cancer.
So then, okay, well, where's my risk reward here?
You know, if your cancer is fairly stable,
well, then certainly use methyl groups, but if to help lower your homocysteine levels,
but you do want to be rechecking your homocysteine levels on a regular basis,
probably every few months,
the simple blood test to do to make sure you're not, you know,
taking it for no reason whatsoever.
Should we still send pictures?
Should we still sort of test results?
Can you still people see people one-on-one?
Yes, you can still send pictures.
We do put them in your file.
Should you still send some test results?
You certainly can submit test results.
Do you see people one-on-one?
No, we can't see people one-on-one anymore.
So understand, I know this is frustrating for you.
Times it by 10, and then that's the frustration that we're feeling, okay?
So you could just, you know, be frustrated.
I want you to be frustrated.
I just want you to be frustrated at the right people.
So don't be mad at us.
We are exhausted and very sad about all what's happening,
having to fight this many fronts.
So please understand that.
So you're reviewed by Holesacity Results,
recommended the methyl supplements.
So my question is, what am I corrected?
So the methylated supplements and your B vitamins will help reduce
homocysteine levels.
So that's what you're trying to do is reduce the homocysteine level
in your blood.
That's the whole purpose.
So back to the, should we still send pictures?
You can, should you?
No, you don't have to.
You can if you want to.
Should you still send, send it test results?
You can, especially if you have a question about a test that you want to ask
on the Zoom call, but those all have to be addressed on the Zoom call.
So you could send, maybe it would be better to send the just the abnormal findings
in the Zoom call question box, which is similar to this blue question box at the bottom of every
page of the member site, but it doesn't say requested.
I'll say it says send submit a question.
So that would probably be the better thing to do is just submit the abnormal findings.
If you have a question about it, like somebody has a question about alcohol and phosphatase
down here, we'll get two in a couple of minutes.
They just submitted it in the question box, which I think would be more appropriate.
So at this point based on bowel movements,
my tumor is still restricting things, not much improvement there,
but it, but we won't know and tell the next MRI to help.
I believe your program is working.
Certainly situation is slightly better with no additional spread.
And more importantly, I feel generally good, though I do feel restrictions in the colon.
I do have bone and bone in my left hip, and that is not related to the cancer.
And it appears that no hip replacement surgery will be appropriate until some sort of
alopathic intervention takes place or the tumor is going.
So I think this person is being restricted to do any type of hip replacement surgery until
he agrees to do colon surgery or so I think that's the situation.
After suggestion, I investigated the prolo therapy as well as stem cell therapy.
And but the doctor said I was not a candidate after seeing the x-rays.
So that's unfortunate. So let's be pretty bad.
So stem cell therapy could be really beneficial, but if you're really, really bone on bone,
then it just, it just may not work at all.
The other thing that you could, I will say that you that I know people have had success with.
is ozone injections. So there is a rogue doctor in Minnesota.
I think she is still doing it is doing ozone injections.
And it was really for people with disk issues and bone on bone issues because she was injecting
ozone right into the site. So you may find somebody locally that's doing that.
Look up doctors who are doing ozone.
And I think there was mixed benefits. And I get anything this is, you know, a serious condition
when it's bone on bone is a chance that that's going to help us. Probably not really great,
but it can get you through for sure. Back to a question on the blog. I'm really sorry.
I'm not asking my questions, right? I guess. What function? What is the function of homocysteine?
What damage is done when it's high? How does it affect detox pathways to a growth?
Homocysteine does not affect to a growth does not affect detox pathways.
Homocysteine can damage your artery. So you don't want to have high homocysteine
for a long time because you can, you can etch your arteries. That's the whole reason why you want to
decrease homocysteine. So, and you could look up homocysteine there, maybe other, you know,
I have to look it up and see what other functions homocysteine, you know, understand everything in your
body, all your metabolites are none of them are just all bad. You know, they serve a good function,
but in excess they can serve a bad function. It's all about balance. Have you ever heard of it
there? It'd be called E, both E, B, O, O, no. I don't know what that is.
All right, let's go to these other questions here. I'm experiencing numbness and slight discomfort
on the right side of the prostate area from the sit bone to the scrotum and an occasional stinging
feeling near the scrotal area. I also have my own chills all over my body,
during waking hours and normal activity. I do not experience chills while resting.
I also feel my own flaws and tired feeling. I assume these annoying and uncomfortable
experience are the result of the cancer spreading. Well, and that is, you know, that is the possible
reason, you know, that the cancer could be spreading. It just could be, you know, the cancer is
irritating a nerve that's affecting that area too. So it could be something else too. So could,
you know, this person has prostate cancer, I believe, you could have prosthetic hypertrophy
along with it, that could be causing neurological damage too. The only way to know that your cancer
spreading or not is to go back and do the same tests that diagnosed it in the first place, the size
of it in the first place. I consider that I'm in the minor pain category of the comparative
pain scale chart, productive cutters. Please suggest some remedies that will significantly reduce
these experiences. Note that two ibuprofen soft gel capsules, the day significantly reduce,
eliminate the chills and block feeling and the uncomfortable nagging numbness after experiences
for the better part of the day. I do not take two capsules a day regularly, but two capsules a few
times to monitor the effect. Okay, so if ibuprofen helps in two soft gel capsules, probably four
hundred milligrams of ibuprofen, you know, that's not a whole lot of ibuprofen. So that I would
consider, you know, what would be a possible nutritional approach that would be a more natural
approach. Well, then you think about things like up into your curcumin. It just goes back to your
anti-inflammatory. So like curcuclear would be an option. And maybe the liposomal form of curcuclear,
which is the liposomal curcuclear, or I think the clear inflame, which has a bunch of other
anti-inflammatories like Boswellia, Stiggy Nettle, White Willow Bark, Rosemary, I think some other
anti-inflammatories. So I would think I would up those whatever I have like inflammatory type symptoms,
my new favorite is the liposomal curcuclear that I've just kept on my desk and I just gulp it
right out of the bottle. So I take maybe a tablespoon. If I'm having issues a couple of times a day
like today, I took several times today. So, or the curcuclear capsules work too. So anti-inflammatories
would be the go-to thing. Thank you. Glad, very blessed to have crossed paths with you. Thank you.
I have a close by blood work from yesterday. I'm very excited. Besides by
15-3, this is your CA-15-3, which is cancer tuber marker. That's more specific to breast cancer.
Going down a couple of weeks ago, my CEA went down. That's another tuber marker. So if you don't know
what these things are, go to the post on tuber markers. So you should search right there on
tuber markers and see if, you know, what those things are. So is there a tuber marker that you could
use to monitor your cancer? So just like this person, how could you monitor prostate cancer? Are there
tuber markers that monitor prostate cancer? Well, really not really, but PSA. PSA prostate
specific estrogen is a tuber marker for prostate cancer. None of the other ones really are
specific to prostate cancer, but you have PSA that you could use. So my CEA went down this time,
also 12.95. Now that is a super, super significant drop. So CEA is one of those with a really tight
margin. Like 15-3 and 99, I think normal in zero to 35 or something like that. CEA is below
five as normal, below 3.5 if you're not a spokeer, is normal. So it's a very tight margin for CEA. So
it went from 12.95. That's a huge drop. That's huge. Question I have is that alkaline phosphate
went up a few points. Is this any concern? So this gets back to what I was talking about way back
of one of these questions. Is that the number one reason for some of the liver markers
in the metabolic panel. So this would alkaline phosphate is one of the markers that will be tested in
what's called a complete metabolic panel or a CMP. That is going to measure liver markers and
your cholesterol and cholesterol breakdown and your albumin and your other protein markers,
your STALT and your alkaline phosphatase. Alicine phosphatase will go up as I've stated multiple times
if you have bony lytic attack on bones. If you have metastasis to the bone and the bone is being eaten
away, which 95% of the time with bony metastasis of cancer, it's a lytic metastasis where the
bone is being eroded. Alkaline phosphatase will rise, but it will typically spike.
And you'll get a calcium level increase as well. But the number one cause of increase in alkaline
phosphatase and a change in any of the other liver markers is a toxicity of the liver or congestion
of the liver, but really toxicity of the liver. And the number one by far cause of that is medications.
So if you're taking any medication, that's your culprit almost always.
You're really, when you're looking at alkaline phosphatase, it goes up a few points. First of all,
the range of alkaline phosphates is pretty high. So if it goes up a few points, it could be nothing.
And it probably does mean nothing. There's a plus to minus probably 10 to 15 points on alkaline
phosphatase with its normal blood test abnormalities and reading abnormalities.
So, but if it's spiked way up, that would be a concern, but still your first
finger pointing would be to medications are taken off. Say, I'm not taking any medications,
I haven't taken any medication, not even anything for a long time. Well, then you'd have to start
digging it into, do you have any metastasis to bone? But you always point to, you always have to
point to medication use. Even taking ibuprope people have a sensitivity to ibuprofen or Tylenol
and it can change their alkaline phosphates really, even taking a couple a day, even a couple a week
can be affected by that. So I would suggest that it's, that you don't have to worry about it, you
are taking medication that would not even consider any that at all abnormal.
This is the same, another question from the same person that's there on ibuprofen. So ibuprens
is a daily use chemotherapy for breast cancer and some other female cancers, and that definitely
is going to affect your liver. So there's your alkaline phosphatase problem. Also taking both
these ameta and phosphidex question I have, once again, is body order, begin body order is quite often
because your body's trying to detox poisons. And these medications though, they may be really
helping you. So I'm not saying don't go on the medication, but this is the side effects of some of
this stuff. So you're just going to have to be using a lot of essential oils or something.
Megan started to be on dihydrobermarine and buried my break on ibuprofen. She's talked about
starting laminate. Does it sound okay with the protocol I'm on? Yes. So you can't really go wrong with
burmarine laminate. I would just say you go slow on it, don't, you know, and Megan knows it's not
to go fast on it too. So I've had long talks with her. So one of my cords on the right had a short,
so I had not been able to run the immune support last week should be getting the ball back tomorrow.
So don't assist me here. Problem with the right machine. Do not try to fix it yourself. You have a
problem with the cord. Get it to try and get it fixed like this person did. You know, you might be
out of it for a few days, but it's worth it getting corrected the right way. Anything else to bring
up my white blood cell count. Just your immune support. You just need as much your, you know,
your aloevia immune product. That's a polysaccharide with a specific chain polysaccharide that is
one of the best things to build up your immune system medicinal mushrooms, which we have multiple
different medicinal mushroom mix on our store, turkey tail mushroom. The my community mushroom from host
defense is a good one. Our medicinal mushroom blend powder is a good one. If you're using a smoothie,
you can throw it in that. I think most of the rife programs finished completely. Okay, this is a
question that somebody emailed in. So remember, please, please, please always send your questions in
on the member site, not email site. We can't take email questions anymore.
So, but the notice that their rife is completely finishing, the programs aren't completely finishing. So
please look at the rife resources page on your member site. We've addressed this and this is
definitely one of the frequently asked questions. You shouldn't be looking at the numbers on your rife.
When you're running your rife, the frequencies that are coming out of the bulb are also hitting the
computer. And they are messing up the, you know, the computer's ability to really understand what's going
on. So sometimes it deal people will get upset. Hey, the, the count, count out is not right. It's saying
I still have seven hours to go when I'm in running this eight hour program for six hours already.
This is not right. It's because the frequencies are affecting the computer. Understand, when you
hit run on your computer on your program, it sends the entire program to the box to the little rife
machine. You could unplug the computer. You could take the computer and turn it off. You could bring
the computer in the other room. You could go run over the computer with your car. The program is still
going to run. So it'll run to the, the whole program will run. So don't worry about that. Don't worry
about what your rife program says afterwards. It's going to get feedback from the frequencies and
mess that up quite often. So don't worry about that. If this is not a new question, I apologize, but if
you could no longer do cheek swabs, how do I know if you're very talked about the right changes?
I had a relative recommend Prodicell. So Prodicell is something that I think is a great protocol.
But we'll talk about the caveats of that. So I write a lot about Prodicell. As a matter of fact,
you could look up information on Prodicell in my book or you could look up information to
Prodicell on our blog. All right, I bought Prodicell 50, but later read somewhere where Prodicell
30 is the type. So there's a Prodicell 30. So there's a Prodicell 50 and there's a Prodicell 23.
Was the type recommended to help with prostate cancer? So I would disagree with that.
Prodicell 50 is really the type to use for prostate cancer. Prodicell 23 is the type you use for any
other cancer. So you did buy the right one. So that was good. Half a model of 50 left who
beneficial manage you have prostate cancer. Yes. So the instructions say things like
co-cutated vitamin C reduce the effectiveness of Prodicell, which is correct. So Prodicell
is an oxidizing agent. So when you're taking Prodicell 50, for instance, you have to take
Prodicell on a very tight schedule. It says it right on the model. I think with Prodicell 50,
it's every five hours or every four and a half hours. You have to take your other supplements
at hour 2.5 right in between doses. So let's say you're taking it at eight o'clock
and then at 12.30 you have to take your Prodicell at 10.30 or you have to take your other
supplements at 10.30. The makers of Prodicell and I actually interviewed one of the inventors of
Prodicell, but I lost the interview so I never got it. This is back when I first did my
wrote by a book in 2010. It was actually before that. He was he recommends that if you can, so if you're
new to the cancer and you're going to do try Prodicell as a therapy, you don't take any anti-oxidants.
So co-Q10, vitamin C, alpha-lopeic acid, glutathione, glutathione precursors, all those things are
anti-oxidants that you would have to take either. You'd either go off of those for a period of time
while you're doing a Prodicell protocol or you have to take them mid between doses of Prodicell.
That's the key. If you take your anti-oxidants at the same time, you take your Prodicell
basically you're negating the benefits of the Prodicell. You're really not going to give yourself a
fair shake on whether Prodicell is going to work. You certainly can just pulse your anti-oxidants
and you certainly could pulse your Prodicell. Maybe you take your anti-oxidants on the weekend and
you only do the Prodicell five days a week during the week. You can do things like that. Get creative.
So we're trying to get you to pray about your Prodicell. What you're going to do and so that you
are taking responsibility for your health and developing that relationship with God that you need to have
so that you could hear his still small voice in your heart leading you. I can't hear that. There's
no one to do. I need somebody to tell me what to do. I don't know what to do. I get it. But this is
what maturity is all about. We need to all mature to that level to be able to hear him.
Jesus said by sheep here by voice and I know them so we need to just be still and know that he is God
and ask him to lead us in the ways that we're supposed to go and the things that we're supposed to do.
My street treatment recommendations stipulated no dairy. Would this restrict me from using
organic ghee? So typically if you're going to use organic ghee you're going to use it to spread
on toast or something like that. So we have said and it's in your binder that yeah you could use some
ghee. Don't worry about that. Even if you're on no dairy we've had people ask well can I put a little
bit of cream I only use a tablespoon in my coffee every day. Is that bad? Okay remember this is
a diet. This is a recommendation. This isn't a cult. So of course you could do that. You know it's
it's just hey I'm not going to be eating cheese. I'm not going to be eating you know I'm
I'm restricting the greater part of dairy consumption that I've had. Well I could drop my dairy
consumption by 90%. You're going to have a huge impact on growth factors. So don't make this
a obsessive compulsive cult-ish lifestyle. You know you just you do the best you can. Certainly
you use it organic ghee. I just have no trouble with that.
Hyperbaric oxygen therapy, HBOT therapy was listed as a treatment recommendation on my genetic
summary. And researchy that treatment I found in a number of places that describe the treatment as
including breathing 100% oxygen. I assume through a mask or under a nose tube. So I don't know
anywhere where you could breathe 100% oxygen that would be I think dangerous and probably deadly.
So I'm not familiar with that whatsoever. Being in a chamber tend with pressurized oxygen is
what hyperbaric oxygen is. My doctor also has HBOT available during my first treatment. I was
surprised that he did not include breathing 100% oxygen. So I talked about that already.
It only included the pressurized chamber. So that's what I would do. I would just do HBOT chamber.
So yeah, just do the HBOT chamber. I got pretty sick December 2nd loss of energy. Could eat
much I thought I was better before Christmas. But now if I need sinus and respiratory
mucus coffee shortly after Christmas I notice more lumps under my left breast. At least two
between my breast putting pressure on my chest and two more on my right breast. I'm writing my
right machine regularly for immune stimulation. Stimulation of cancer frequencies. Is there
anything else you would suggest? So if you notice growth like this kind of thing, this is where you
really have to pray about doing some other intervention. I don't remember who we've been asked this
question. But I don't, you know, I so I apologize if you already explored that avenue. But this is where
you don't want to have a dogmatic position against doing some chemotherapy to knock things down. I
can't tell you how many breast cancer patients that that over the years I've had to, you know,
let's talk about doing some chemotherapy. Now we can have those talks but we can do it over the
zoom call. That don't feel bad about if that's if you haven't explored that option to explore that
option. Continue with multiple animals. So does and what detoxes certainly. So from a gerson standpoint,
if you're having issues, they would push you to do up to five animals a day. The more you can stimulate
your parasympathetics, the better, the better the purpose of the coffee animals to stimulate your
parasympathetic nervous system, which is going to stimulate your detoxification pathways and
stimulate your immune function to fight any disease, certainly cancer. During my most recent swab
three months ago, we had an infant bandisol. Should I continue to take that? Well, if you're getting
gross growth like this, you have to consider up being the infant bandisol. So if I put you on a pack
a day, try to do some different things like increase that. That's one possibility. Go to the protocol page
on the membership site. Go to the protocol page and then go to breast cancer protocol and look at
the four or five different protocols that I've put together for breast cancer that maybe you are not
doing right now that you should add one of those protocols. This is where look at those and go, I'm using
this really using most of this protocol and really using some of this protocol and really using some
of this protocol, but about doing anything about this and pray about whether that's something you should
add or to increase of the fed bandisol. Still doing time restricted eating four times a week,
on glucose reading mid-morting, typically 75 to 85. Now it's showing over 100, 506. So another thing,
another protocol that I would have been putting up that I just did an interview with
gentleman named Alan Cash. Alan Cash is a physicist who started all the research on a product
called oxaloacetate and oxaloacetate is a metabolite that is found in the creb cycle. So you remember
high school biology, the creb cycle. So the creb cycle is what is how you make ATP, right? So ATP
is energy. So ATP is if you don't have ATP, you're dead, right? So ATP is the energy, little capsules
that function in your muscles to create function of your muscles that function in your every single cell
of your body requires ATP and every single cell of your body makes ATP in the cell itself in one of the
organelles in the cell called the mitochondria. So the mitochondria, which you have thousands of mitochondria
in your cells in each cell, they are responsible really for making ATP. So within the cytoplasm of the cell,
you have glycolysis taking place in the mitochondria, glycolysis taking place, glycolysis takes glucose.
So glycolysis takes glucose, you need glucose, right? So glucose is broken down through glycolysis
to make pyruvate. So pyruvate, well ultimately pyruvate, but pyruvate will break down
to make lactic acid. And then lactic acid can be used in a, as a poor use of energy production
because you only use, you only make two ATP through, through anaerobic energy production through
glycolysis, especially if you have an HIF1 gene defect. So it's getting technical as you can look
at the genetic, I put a whole video together on genetics with the HIF1 gene defect.
But that's what happens. That's what's called the warberg effect. So many times in cancer, you are,
you are not able to get your glucose into the crem cycle. And that's what can feed cancer.
So oxaloacetate is a component in the crem cycle that is if you add oxaloacetate as a
supplement, you actually break down the warberg effect. So the cancer can't feed directly
off glucose nearly as well. So added oxaloacetate as a supplement can help break down the cancer
ability to feed on glucose. Well, how do I know if my cancer is feeding on glucose? Well,
what is if in your genetics, you have a high amount of HIF1 genes. And in your genetic report that
we have given you, we would have highlighted that and because we call it a tumor suppressor gene,
but actually nobody else does. I call it a tumor suppressor gene because defects on the HIF1
gene can cause the warberg effect. So I listed as a tumor suppressor gene that what doesn't
function technically as a tumor suppressor gene. Also, if you have something like this,
normally my glucose is 75 to 85. And I have a change by diet whatsoever. Nothing's changed. Now it's
over 100, 105, 106. It's quite possibly what's taking place is the warberg effect. And it's quite
possibly added oxaloacetate would be the thing to do. Now, oxaloacetate is available. We have it in
just two forms. It's really two dosages that the the Alan Cash, the owner of a Terra biologicals,
they make the product in the by the name of Benagine. Number of you are on Benagine. So Benagine
is oxaloacetate, but their label Benagine is 100 milligrams of oxaloacetate. So that's still a good
dose to start with. You could take three a day. That's what they recommend. Three a day of the Benagine
and in that dosage. Or now they have a high dose of oxaloacetate and they call it, I think it's
oxaloacetate. Now it's common. What's it called? Let me look it up really quick.
If I'm talking about it. CFS I think it's that's what it is. It's called oxaloacetate CFS.
Think about it for a second. And the reason why it's called CFS is because they did all these studies
on it for a credit fatigue syndrome. Because people that have serious credit fatigue syndrome
serious COVID post COVID long call COVID symptoms of fatigue, it's because of the same thing.
They are functioning their cells are only being fed through the warberg effect. So the warberg effect
was described by Otto Warberg. I lay it out in detail in my book. If you want to get into it,
you can google the warberg effect back in the 1930s. He described the warberg effect as that's how
cancer is fed. Not all cancer is fed that way, but certainly a lot of cancer is fed that way. That's
why we take you off of high sugar diets. That's why you don't want to be eating candy if you got cancer
because you can propagate the warberg effect. And one of the ways that you can break that is through
using oxaloacetate. So the product is betegine is the low dose or lower dose and oxaloacetate CFS
is the high dose. So that's more expensive. Certainly what's higher expensive product because it's
just based upon dosage. So you could certainly start with betegine, start with three of those a day
to see if that can make the changes that you want to take. They are currently doing studies. They're
actually doing a study of with male that's starting I think next month to glioblastoma. The initial
studies that they did is with astrocytomas and glioblastomas and then the FDA made them take that all
off their website. Isn't it wonderful? Even though it was proven to be very effective with brain cancers.
So it does reduce glutamate in the brain as well. That's another thing benefit of oxaloacetate. That's
why it would be so helpful with brain cancers as well. But the key functional component and the
mechanism of action with any other cancer is that it can break the warberg effect. So then you go
well, let's say if I don't have cancer, if my body is functioning stuck in the warberg effect,
what could it cause? Well, the number one thing it could cause is imbalancing your hormones so it
could be a major issue with PMS issues and chronic fatigue, fibromyalgia type symptoms. People that have
maybe blaming their symptoms on long-term Lyme disease or tick-borne illnesses, it could really be
that they're stuck in the warberg effect. And certainly fatigue with cancer can give you an idea that
you can be stuck in the warberg effect. So using Benagene, which is a brand name from terobiologics,
oxaloacetate is a good option to go. And I'll have more of that information. I just did it. I just
actually interviewed him. I knowed him for a number of years. We've been using Benagene in our office.
Oh gosh, for 12, since 2006, when he first came up with it, I met him at a conference. And
then we have, we speak all the time. So I just did an interview with him on our podcast.
Apologize already with that question and twice. Okay, so this person had a long question, but it was
just stating some of the things that they're doing. And then they said, can we do something about
the side effects of dry gums. This is side effects from radiation. So this person was doing radiation
on a tumor near their neck. And the side effects are coarse damage to the organ. So dry gums,
dry mouth, throat feels dry, uncomfortable. What do you do with the side effects of that? Well,
you really have to look at what's a cause of that. It's probably radiation affecting the
prodigland. So saliva production is going to be done. So there's not any like perfect answer to this.
So the radiation is working. And the tumor is decreasing. Praise God for that.
There's going to be side effects that you're going to have to just deal with. And in its best ways,
is possible. So obvious things are trying to drink. I would suggest doing oil in a way that you put
like a tablespoon of coconut oil in your mouth. Let it melt in your mouth because it'll melt
instantly in your mouth and swish it around, swish it around, swish it around and spit it out
into the toilet and leave that coating of oil on your mouth then too. That can be helpful.
So having a kind of a coating of coconut oil on your mouth and on your throat would be beneficial
with this when you have a decreased parotin function. You have a decreased saliva function.
There is a product that would possibly help with this. That is, let me pull it up really quick here.
That is by biotics research. It's called cytoside perottid.
And that's by biotics research. I'll put it right down here so you can see it.
cytoside perottid T.S. because it 180 capsules take about three a day or so. That is perottid tissue
from a bovine perottid tissue that could help rebuild the perottid gland. That's an option.
I would try that too. Can I eat lilies dark chocolate bars? I'd say yes.
But I wouldn't stop doing the radiation if it's working because of the side effects. I would
try to do my best to deal with the side effects and continue that. If they're trying to push you
towards chemo too, I just asked them, again, like we talked about last time, just continue to try
to ask them the tough questions about, well, how would this benefit? How do you really think, would
you tell your father to do this? Just be honest with me. I just asked them those kind of tough questions.
Without to use a cheek swab, I'm wondering what you would advise me to change my protocol. My
college is says one of my non-general services increases in size. I think we touched on that. Go to
the protocol section of the member site. Look at the protocols that you're not maybe doing
anything else that you could add to the picture. I would certainly add to the picture.
What information do you have on antideal clastins that have been used to help kill cancer? You
can certainly go to Dr. Przyski's site. He's got a clinic down in Houston, I believe.
And you can look at his information on there. I do write about antideal clastins in my book. You
can look at that as well. Okay, some of your chat questions have decided to go to the immunotherapy
clinic in Mexico that we discussed. Surgeon still has a calm goodness. Continue looking to
allow back to me surgery and they might be able to consult with you about that and it may even be
able to do it down there. So I look into that. So that's good. Thank you. I think I've depleted my
electrolytes and minerals. I've had a hard time with my stomach and couldn't get anything down.
I think after doing so much infrared soda and animals without doing juice supplements,
just weren't enough. I woke up very dizzy, twitched my right eye. Yeah, so you can deplete your
minerals and it can get rebalanced even with a normal diet really quick, but it's really quick to
deplete your minerals. You know, especially if you have diarrhea or you're sick with the flu and
you're throwing up or something like that. So again, the supplement for minerals that I would suggest
would be the clear multimids is what I would suggest to use. For prolo therapy, check out Dr.
Hauser in Florida. He really helped my sister wrote the book on the therapy. Oh, thank you for that.
Big sweetheart loves God. Maybe that would be a second opinion. So people can't see that. I guess
I can't copy and paste them. Sorry about that. We copied into that pace from that. So I think
you already can see that chat here. Dr. Hauser in Florida. So if you could look into that.
Oh, message to look at that again. Could the rife have caused some detox and kick this further?
You're talking about causing more of the decrease in electrolytes. Well, only if you're doing the
foot bath, certainly I wouldn't think anything else. A reference slide 14 maybe be slide 12 earlier slide.
I'm going to repost here. Tuxer remedies that invite a bit D magnesium B12 and the green
drink, which I've been doing, I was going to eat as well, feeling a little bit better, but thought
earlier I was going to pass out or have a stroke. Oh, goodness. Well, make sure that you are being
careful in your taking care of yourself. I did not do it anyway yesterday or today and haven't
done so enough for four days as I feel something wasn't right. Any suggestions. If you have the ability
to go get a blood test, that would be really good. You should get your electrolytes tested and that
would be a CBC and a complete metabolic panel. You want to go in and get tested, so for sure do that.
So again, the feeling of light headed this and things you start thinking of a decreased blood pressure
could cause that a certainly electrolyte balance could cause that adrenal fatigue caused that,
but you want to go in and get that checked out. You don't want to be making the mistake and not playing with it.
Okay, so complete question. Ecladial apathetic, we're going to call it an update difference.
Just increase fentanyl to 222 grams instead of three times per week.
November contacted oncologist, bio hospitals, as a result, had a CT scan due to December 14th to
December winter storms, MRI rescheduled for the 25th results of the CT scan.
Lever lungs look clean, reduction in size in the largest lymph node, no discussion on size of two
or other lymph nodes, not distinctions when we addressed at the MRI.
Interesting note that oncologist directed latest scans to be the same machines as the original,
which is the right thing to do. So you could have discrepancy over the different machines,
and believe it or not, you could have discrepancy over what radiologist reads in the report.
That's why gold standard is really highly subjective.
As of December 14th, 3T scans to monitor progress, lots of inaccuracies
info for radiologists interpretations. Well, there you go. You,
Iowa oncologist suggests due to variations between machines. Yes, that's exactly right.
And I realized that this was so critical here's a link to discussion that kind of issue
at this point based on bowel movements to where it's still restricting things, not much improvement.
We'll go with the details until the next MRI. So this is what we talked about.
That part of it. So sometimes I understand when you guys submit a question, I'm not going to put the
all the data in that I don't necessarily think that every person needs to know your history.
So to partly protect your privacy and to be able to do the zoom call within 60 minutes,
which now are 15 minutes over that time, I don't put all your data in. Which essential oils would help?
I'm not sure. Help what if you're using essential oils for cancer.
Themselves, levied grass, fracon scents,
corpoia, corpova are good essential oils. There's lots of essential oils that are good for cancer.
Also, topical essential oils if you're trying to kill like a fungus and things, a regular oil,
one of the best, if you're using
um, yeah, livid themes is a good essential oil for that. What I buy D3, what are other
complementary letters to get along with it? So we have the our ADK mail and our ADK complete,
which is the same thing, which are all the fat soluble vitamins in one supplement.
Where's I put the right for the pancreas, the funter, the backside? I put it on your belly.
Also, I stopped most supplements five days ago because my stomach felt so yucky. That's good. It's,
it can be good to help. Pause some things to kind of clean yourself out too.
Are you familiar with homeopathic called bach flowers? Bach flower remedies are mainly to help with,
yes, for emotions, familiar. What is your opinion? I think they're great. I think it's great to use
bach flower remedies. So there's nothing wrong with using bach flowers. They're certainly not
too wrong with using homeopaths. I started pectosol C, got diarrhea, a week straight, cut back to
one scoop in hand to stop. Better now. Will I be able to incorporate this at some time?
That's the first time I've ever had anybody have a reaction to pectosol C, but that doesn't mean
that's not true. So people can have a reaction to things you could have a sensitivity to something
in there. So will you ever be able to go back up to that? I don't know. Yeah, that severe reaction,
you know, it could have been something that you were taking with it, something your diet was going
on. It could be completely unrelated. Maybe it's not the bach'sol C at all, but it certainly seems
like it. I would give it a couple of weeks off, and then I would try back on a maybe a quarter
scoop and see if you have any type of upset, kind of keep an eye on it, and then talk, think about
taking cool, you know, up in it if you're not. Can we see you personally in your office? No,
we can't do that either. Croger makes a good organic dark chocolate bar cheaper than lilies,
and lilies isn't organic. Oh, that's interesting. If you have a Croger around you,
we don't have Croger's around us, but probably find that in other stores too.
But I also suggest homeopathic remedy ignition for emotions. Yes, so there's a lot of great homeopaths
out right now. I don't know if you've caught the last month, the FDA is trying to shut down homeopathy.
Isn't that wonderful? So, of course, they don't try to shut down something unless it works.
Did you decide to do another Q&A? Not yet, not yet. Okay, I don't know if the audio is breaking up,
or my voice is breaking up. So with that, I am going to have to say goodbye to everybody. So
thank you all for participating. Please do understand and look at what we posted on here. So
I understand everybody wants to get their questions answered and know that I will do my best to answer
everybody's questions. But you know, I don't want to limit people to even only answer what or ask what
or two questions. But I also want you know, to be as respectful as you can to
search for the answers that we've already provided as best you possibly can.
So with that, know that I'll be prayed for all you. I love you all, and I will talk again next week. Bye-bye.